you've been doing this a long time you
are you are not the youngest man in the
game but you're doing action in my
opinion better than ever what's your
secret how are you able to stay young
and and be able to do these kicks and
these punches so well at at this stage
in your career it's because I came up to
a point that you've got kind of listen
you have to listen to your body and it's
good to train about three times a week
if you can four and sometimes you don't
feel like training and you do one time a
week which is not enough but maybe
enough you've got to understand your
body and to have a relationship of a
feeling with the body so when I'm saying
that stretching is the is the start of
putting muscle on your body because with
stretching you first reinforced your
tendon you need like cable when the
cable are strong and they can resist
then we can put the meat on it and to
train too heavy and all that stuff it's
not good later on you'll have back
problems neck problems so it's better a
lots of repetition so the blood goes in
you don't have to train heavy you do the
movement correctly so what happened it's
perfect and and your muscles they have a
lots of endurance and you open your
rivers which mean when you train lots of
reps yeah you have a lots of blood so
your veins they open up which is better
for your cardiovascular I'm not gonna do
any of that but but I cannot get what I
can do I can show you like one or two
three moves you could show me something
yes okay
what should I do some stretching some
stretches cuz I am NOT the most limber
man not if you want to lay on the floor
is it better here there is a second man
today to ask me this is fine right here
yes good on your back on my back right
here okay I'm being trained by realized
man down and and and you have to relax
your partner so what you do you bend one
leg only up to here okay yeah
and I'll do the same with the other one
I can't feel anything yeah that's right
and I go here and I put his to Hill
together
yeah and with my knee I hold him but
I've got not to bring it oh my god guys
please please it's mine claims yes and
no it's so it's so crazy to dream
something at night and then it happens
the next day
okay now I put one hand here yeah I am
and the other one and slowly I push
towards the floor and I can feel you're
flexible
I am I actually do try and stretch I'm
not chunk like on Tom and then I do try
and strut and I do one leg uh-huh and
it's not pushing like this like an
elevator like a slow push and I can feel
your tendon your abductor uh-huh and I
go to the other side and that's one of
the first movement then when you stop
relax and I bring you back slowly that's
one of the move okay I have a question
yes am I supposed to be bleeding in here
no but like for example if if I if I'm
like this yeah and you know that's a
good position as you mentioned about my
movies respect the show but I don't care
about him anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
nope hi-y let me see you do the famous
split you do the famous yeah how do I do
I want to know is it something I could
ever achieve in my life this is as much
of a split as I can do it's very
possible for me at this stage in my life
to do more yes what should do uh-huh
you'll be okay to stand up yeah of
course that's I'm not an 80 year old man
don't stand up yeah and what about you
yeah yeah all right corner yeah here
okay what you're gonna put your legs
yeah and be careful yeah up here on that
table yes okay do it from your hand Oh
perfect
okay perfect okay no you find a good
position like this right yeah yeah and
try to stretch your legs but also the
back has to be straight right including
the neck okay so no I look like such an
[ __ ] right now you know great so
slowly you take your legs and you go
ladies if you go to a gym and a guy is
doing this and just looking around call
the police yeah okay if you like to go
down like this you absolutely slowly but
this next has to be more here yeah what
do you mean where you put too much
pressure the backlight move it oh okay
well good that's enough that's self
stretch that one yeah and very important
always at all now is the toe up like
this okay even when you fight because if
your legs when you do a kick that's it
and you do the other one okay but how
does that get me to the splits I want to
do the splits that a split is this one I
have another one show me your split can
you know inspiration to this yeah you
put out [ __ ] odds
hey no no listen listen you could come
in front of me come oh now you want me
here no on the other side no on the
other side
on the other side
police understanding and you open your
knee all right okay and no you just open
your legs like this okay right okay same
with the other one okay and and okay
what you do you put one form here get
one there yeah and then you feel you
feel the pressure you have and if you
feel yourself you can feel yourself or
flexible you are and you wait and you
watch TV you watch like a TV show you
watch out on a Brian yeah or pornography
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys bring it out bring it out here's
what I want to get you I want to get
drunk live on Dom I want to get to this
point in my life where I'm just
can you imagine people if you were
walking down the street and you saw
jean-claude Van Damme and I like this
just scoping out anyone who passes by
I'd be a great wingman we're gonna take
this is my favorite part right hell okay
[Applause]
you